And everybody, welcome to another Zoom call and a lot of questions that came in today where this week.
So we'll jump right into it. Make sure you chat in your questions. If you have any other questions that you think about while we're talking.
Always look for announcements. There actually is several new announcements on today's.
The member site and one of them is as we were switching up a few things. So we always allowed self scheduling.
But the truth is we actually lowered the prices or our.
Our office visits about a year ago for people who weren't full members.
Out of the member price just because of the kind of recession trying to help people out.
Well, we went back to our old prices for the non members.
And when I'm speaking about non members, I'm speaking about not you.
So anybody listening to this is a full comprehensive member that's what you get with the Zoom calls.
So don't self schedule for you guys that are full comprehensive members. Don't self schedule.
That's why I got to cross through this.
Call it because you get the discounted price to $135. We went back to the $25 price, which was always our old price for our visits.
So you want to keep you guys still get you guys still get the discounted price. So just so you let you know.
Can a person ever overuse the right machine?
I've had tonight is for 55 years, possibly as a result of a wish with flash from a sledding incident.
And have been using the tonight's program since February 1st.
I'm starting to have redness and heat spots on my face in the tops of my feet.
I'm not sure if these symptoms are a result of the right program.
But this is the only change I've implemented recently.
I have been using have I been using this too much.
It is an all night program seven eight hour program.
Also the goal that tonight is program is to kill possible parasites of the brain or to store a fire up set abses in the brain cells.
So this person is talking about a true right program for tonight is so the true right program for tonight is I personally didn't write.
So I honestly don't know what's in that program.
If it is aerosite frequencies or not, I haven't looked at that program for years.
So I don't know if it doesn't have any headings.
I have no idea what's what the frequencies are.
Remember every program in your right folder is is a set of different frequencies that the software is telling to run.
And so it depends on what frequencies are there.
So if there are kill frequencies.
So if there are bacterial frequencies or live frequencies or parasite frequencies.
If they are yes, you could be running the right too much.
So remember, you know, if you kill too quickly, if you kill a pathogen too quickly.
A parasite of bacteria or even a virus too quickly, you can you will liberate endotoxins that your liver has to get out.
And if you do kill too quickly, you could overwhelm to your liver detox pathways.
That is the definition of a herximer reaction.
If there are kill programs in that program that are killing gram negative bacteria, you will be liberating lipopolisaccharides, which would definitely give you a herximer reaction.
So I don't know what's in that program.
So yes, you could be killing too much with that.
That's why I say you think you have Lyme disease.
So you're going to run some Lyme programs.
You got to go really slow or you could overwhelm your detox pathways.
You could give yourself a herximer reaction.
So you have to be very careful with that.
So honestly, I did not write that program for tonight.
So I don't know what's in it.
So I would say yes, you got to be careful back off.
Maybe do some detox, do some foot baths, do some copy animals,
other things like that to help your body detox hot packs over your liver, castor packs over your liver to help your body detoxify.
Since taking the clear histamine scavenger, I have been having more loose bowel movements.
So loose bowel movements.
Is this normal with this product?
Also, I'm taking clear iron.
So clear iron would not be causing the loose bowel movements.
It's probably if it is something you're taking, it could be something in the clear histamine scavenger.
And taking anything that is possible, maybe it's helping you flush things out, helping you detox.
Making me think this is why I can't gain weight, whatever it goes right through me.
Yeah, we don't want that to be the case.
So I would say back off of this, the clear histamine scavenger is not the key component for anybody's cancer.
So I would just stop the clear histamine scavenger for a few days and see if this changes.
And keep in contact with me because you never want to be like eating food and then having to run to the bathroom and you just lose it.
Basically, you're not you're not retaining your nutrition long enough for you to absorb enough calories and nutrients from that.
And yes, that can be unhealthy for a person and you can lose weight or fail to gain weight.
So just stop this.
I went highly doubt that it's the iron.
And if it is a product between these two, I did not look at this person's protocol.
But if it is one of these two products, I would definitely say it's the clear histamine scavenger.
I just stop it for a few days, see if this calms down again.
Then I would just stay off of it for maybe a week and then maybe just go on one a day and see if that bothers you and play with your dosage like that.
But do stay in contact with me because we don't want you to be having such loose bowel movements that you're basically not absorbing your nutrients.
The last four nights I have been having night sweats mostly around the head and neck, which is odd.
Is there something I could do for the night sweats any programs?
Bob, I don't so night sweats are a sign of something so it's not necessarily what we want to do for we want to figure out what you're having these night sweats, what it's caused by no person can have night sweats.
If they are on if they have a cancer that is a hormone driven cancer, let's say they have ERPR positive cancer and we have them on an aromatase inhibitor supplement or they're on an aromatase inhibitor medication that can certainly give you night sweats because you're basically what are yourself into an estrogen deprivation.
And that's the goal of those things and you are basically getting these hot flush type things if we have if you don't have that type of cancer and we don't have you on that type of product that there's other reasons why a person gets night sweats.
A person with lymphoma and get night sweats because lymphoma can affect or hormone balance and you can get night sweats from the lymphoma.
So we should really have a discussion with the person who wrote this if you want to call and talk and we should make an appointment.
There are any specific right programs for night sweats, you deal with it, you use the right treatment or nutritional treatment or medication or whatever based upon the cause of it.
So we'd be looking at really those two things and night sweats are either cause from a cancer like a lymphoma or from a hormone disruption like somebody going through benapause or somebody going through a forced reduction in estrogen by taking some sort of aromatase inhibitor product.
Next question, is there a good protein product to use for the goal? So yeah, I recommend the US enzyme protein mixes because they're low in glutamine, there are some protein mixes that have higher glutamine.
I also trust US enzymes because I think of all the supplement companies out there US enzymes and PR are probably the two clearest beating that they're the most anal companies as far as protecting their clients with purity.
So most supplements, the supplement companies have to buy their raw product from some place and whether you like it or not, a lot of raw product is purchased from China.
All the green tea extract, all the EGCG extract in every supplement is there's not made anywhere but China and you know these these producers in China will basically be, you know, discriminate to who they send their clearest stuff to.
If it sends, they send a giant barrel, it comes actually in these giant bags on a pallet, they send a pallet of green tea extract EGCG to US enzymes or PRL, they test the batch not just the top of the batch but they test all the way through the batch.
And if it doesn't, if it tests contaminated at all, it gets sent back the way they have the contract with the company is that they don't have to pay for the shipping and excise fees and everything so they don't ever want to get a batch back.
So clean products are important to me.
I know other companies, you know, do testing as well and we only sell, we only recommend companies that we feel like are the clearest.
And that's a different suite if you equip bought your supplements at Walmart or Walgreens or Target or something like that.
So you want clean supplements, but then when you're looking at a protein powder for a cancer patient, you want a protein powder that has the least amount of glutamated it.
And we've settled out the US enzymes product for that for a protein, they have a chocolate and they have a vanilla, it's very good, we use it a lot and a lot of people like it.
But you know what I've said about protein powders in the past, that's why this person asked this question for how to go is that you're only still getting 20 to 25 grams of protein in a protein powder drink.
Which is far less than you get from a piece of chicken. So it's really hard to get your protein, the, you know, levels up by just, you know, consuming a protein powder.
But I understand if you're on the go, you want to add a little bit of protein to a shake or something, there's nothing wrong with adding a protein powder.
You get that little bit of boost. I would use the protein powder from US enzymes.
A few weeks ago, I had some questions about supplements for my functional doctor, that my functional doctor recommended and your response was a little hesitant maybe because I mixed up some, which supplements were for what problem.
NAC and resveratrol were to help my EO, your methylation for the estrogen methylation protocol.
So this person did a Dutch test that showed E2, which is estradiol.
And it increased in their methylated estradiol, which they wanted to reduce.
And this doctor recommended some products. So we talked about that on the zoom call a few weeks ago.
And they're, so you're clarifying that they're recommending the resveratrol and the anesthetal cysteine for that.
And my only, my only reservation for the anesthetal cysteine is that, you know, that is a glutathione precursor.
And, you know, using it for a period of time to try to reduce that is fine.
But remember that you could be possibly keeping a cancer alive by using anything that's a glutathione or glutathione precursor.
Just keep that in mind.
Rival flavoured and phosphatidylcholine are to help lower the whole assisting levels along with B6 that I'm already taking.
Okay, that sounds fine too.
So again, this is fine. My only reservation was the anesthetal cysteine.
A few weeks ago, I was asking you about resveratrol.
You mentioned that it has a very short half-life, so it takes smaller doses throughout the day.
I was wondering if that holds true for the fermented resveratrol from Premiere Research Lab.
It's the same. Yes.
So, Premiere Research Lab has kind of one of their things.
A lot of their supplements are, they are fermented in batch doses.
I've actually toured their facility down in Austin, Texas, where they make these things quite interesting.
And, they have fermented resveratrol.
I have a lot of you people on the fermented tumeric.
I think it adds to its benefits to the body.
I think it adds to its accessibility as far as absorbability.
So, I think they're great products, but it doesn't shorten their half-life.
So, you'll still, the half-life is just how fast your body breaks down the end product in your tissues into the blood.
So, it still has a very short half-life, so you still want to break it up through the day.
And, that's really goes through, goes for all of your supplements.
The more you can split up your doses, let's say you're supposed to take three a day of something,
and you take them all in the morning, that might not be the best way to dose things for most supplements.
So, it's different with your fat-soluble vitamins, and it's different if you're trying to, you know,
get up to a certain dose of vitamin C so that you have the antioxidant effects of the vitamin C.
So, like vitamin D, you could take that all at once.
You don't need to split that up. That'll store it in your body.
The vitamin A will store it in your body. Vitamin E will store it in your body.
But, a lot of your herbs, they're going to have a half-life. A lot of all your bio-flavanoids are going to have a half-life
that aren't, that isn't real long. So, by splitting it up, you're going to give your body a better benefit
in how you deal with that and how it helps you.
Are there supplements you would generally recommend for someone who has had their thyroid removed?
Would iodine be one of them?
So, if you've had your thyroid removed, now lots of times when you've had your thyroid removed, they didn't remove all of it.
So, you'd want to discover that.
Number two, if you've had your thyroid removed, you definitely are on some sort of synthetic thyroid supplementation.
Maybe it's not synthetic, maybe you're an armor, but you can't survive without thyroid hormone very well.
And you will have to be taking thyroid hormone the rest of your life.
Now, still could a person with no thyroid survive a desiccated thyroid, which is a supplement technically.
Probably not very well, but it could, you know, even desiccated, a good desiccated thyroid like our Echo Thyro-37 or our Clear Thyro-37 is through PHP.
It's just a straight desiccated thyroid. It doesn't have anything else in there.
You know, a lot of thyroid supplements out there put a bunch of other vitamins in there and methylated bees and all this kind of stuff,
because they want to just try to oversell the supplement to this perfect thyroid supplement.
I don't like those.
So, the desiccated thyroid that's solely desiccated thyroid, that's what I like best for thyroid.
Because a person with thyroid issues often has thyroid issues because they have Hashimoto's or maybe they had Graves disease.
That's why they got the thyroid removed or they had a thyroid cancer. They got their thyroid removed.
And you're going to have, you know, you have this, this cold morbidity inhabited autoimmune disease, which already redisposes you to hypersensitivity to triggers that could make your condition worse.
So I like more simple supplements in the case of that where you're only got one thing in there.
And especially with a desiccated glandular, when you're trying to support the thyroid, I would say that.
So, think of a desiccated thyroid could be a possibility. Would I suggest iodine, if you've had your thyroid removed?
No. That makes no sense whatsoever. The only reason why a person would even conceive of taking iodine is that iodine makes up
that part of your thyroid needs iodine to make part of the T3 molecule, which is the act of thyroid hormone.
But there's a lot of misunderstandings about iodine. So most people that are taking iodine should not even be taking iodine even if they have a thyroid.
So I'm not a fan of taking exogenous iodine even if you haven't had your thyroid removed.
And there's an entire section in the autoimmune course on this, the chronic disease and autoimmune course, the module six is all about the thyroid.
So you can go into depth about that. So back to the question, are there supplements that I would recommend generally, if someone had their thyroid removed?
The only thing is to continue to support your beneficial thyroid, your beneficial T3 and T4 levels.
So get in your T3, T4 levels checked to make sure they're within fairly normal range with your current thyroid medication, whether you're taking a synthetic T3, synthetic T3, T4 mix or a synthetic T4.
There's a bunch different thyroid medications that would give you those options. And if you've landed on one that seems to be working fairly well with you and you have your numbers fairly well in balance, but you still are having thyroid symptoms.
So you can have normal in range T3, T4, free T3, free T4, reverse T3 and you're still having thyroid low thyroid symptoms.
That's very common. Well then you can supplement with a desiccated thyroid and to symptomatically to help boost thyroid levels to for functional use of thyroid levels in your body.
So hopefully that answers that. You use desiccated thyroid to supplement your medication if you've had your thyroid removed completely.
Even if you'd haven't had your thyroid completely, you still can use desiccated thyroid supplement to help supplement if you're on a medication like armor or synthroid or whatever you're on to help supplement and balance out your need because you need thyroid hormone throughout the day, depending on your stress level of the day.
So it's not a perfect science of, oh, I got down to XX micrograms of X and X sub medication and it's perfect for me. I said no thyroid patient ever. It was perfect for a period of time and then they feel the crash. How come I'm having still my hair fall out? How come I'm just still tired all the time?
How come I have weight gain? I go, what is wrong with me? I went to the doctor, my blood tests were normal because functionally you're on a daily basis, your need for hormone. It's not just steady state. It depends on your level of stress, depends on your level of physical stress and your hormone need.
You have to supplement with desiccated thyroid to help boost up where you're missing.
So some days with a desiccated product, you might take two of them a day, some days you might take six, some days you might take none.
So it varies depending upon your need for that day. But I would never recommend iodine.
Other colors you recommend in black sand blood root after my cheek swab. Can you explain why and what it does?
So why I recommend anything after the cheek swab is because you tested for it. That's why you said the cheek swab in. So we tested for it and that's what tested.
What does the black sand blood root do? Well, the black sand blood root, if you look on the store and you look at the label, it's got really good.
Cancer killing nutrients in it. The black sand blood root is primarily used as a quote unquote cancer killing product by anybody who's using it.
So it has similar, I think it's got chaperale and blood root and grabbiola and something else. I don't have the label in front of me, but that's why you're using it.
I'm considering going off the cascuali that I have been on. I just found out after a CT scan that a few small areas have grown just a bit after no change in many months.
My legs and my liver, my lungs and my liver mainly. Is it an important change to start the immune in the black sap? Yeah, yes, I do. I think it is an important thing to do. Yes, I have quit doing the vitamin C IV so I can afford the two of those.
You always want when you look at a CT scan, you always want to get a comparison and look at how much of a change in the cancer, how much of a growth and it's always best again to go to the same place.
It'd be great if you could go to this, have the same radiologist read it, you know, no control over that, but I always remember that, you know, you want to, when they're looking at a size of a legion in the lung, remember they're not looking at a three dimensional object, it is like multi dimensional.
And it's really hard to angle that they see it, you know, to really see, you know, you'd want to see a first fairly large percentage of change to get worried about it.
How would you dose the radiation homeopath prior to a PET scan, and how much before the scan would you begin, how long before the scan would you begin to take it, how long after the scan, would you take it?
And how much would you take?
Well, technically, you don't, technically, you don't need to take the radiation homeopath prior to the scan.
I, in my mind, I just think you're kind of prepping your body, start taking it a couple days before your PET scan, that I would just finish the model.
So, I mean, there's no sense, no need to stop it. It's not going to hurt you. It's just going to help pull radiation out of your body.
I mean, to be honest, there's people that take the radiation homeopath and they never got any PET scan, CT scan.
But how often if we got X-rays or dental X-rays or worksposed to radiation, even if you've never gotten an X-ray, worksposed to radiation.
So, there's people that take the radiation homeopath for those reasons too. So, I would finish the model.
I have been doing high dose IV vitamin C treatments, but feel I need to take a break as my veins are getting harder to access.
I read this supplement about, about a last step, extensive extensisin, can be an equivalent to the IVs.
I think we answered this question last week.
Are you familiar with this? And how helpful do you think IV vitamin C is for battling cancer?
Well, I think IV vitamin C can be great for battling cancer, but I don't think there's any wrong with taking a break.
And I think, like I said, last week, I think giving yourself a break on a therapy for a period of time can be beneficial.
And I said last week also that this last I think I have another patient that's taking this high dose extensisin at the topical form.
And he said he's having benefit, but I haven't spoke to him for a couple of weeks now.
What does the word driver mean in our food lists?
A driver in our in our vernacular means something that it could be fueling the cancer.
So if I said a driver was, you know, if estrogen is a driver, that could be quote unquote fueling a cancer.
Was that particularly fueling a cancer in the case of estrogens blocking the estrogen beta receptors, which is an apoptonic receptor, which is blocking apoptosis to a cancer.
But in a food, if there is a driver, then dairy could be feeding the cancer by being a fuel source for the cancer or vice in the case of dairy, it would be basically stimulating through growth hormones through upregulating the mTOR pathway.
Glucose is a driver for the cancer because it's a direct fuel source because glucose breaks down through glycolysis to endpoint to proveic acid and converts to lactic acid, especially if people have hif1ag defects.
So you end up with excess lactic acid and lactic acid is a direct fuel source for cancer.
So the driver means what could be basically fueling or feeding the cancer.
I've been reading through the manual and have not found an answer for the question, how long should I use the daytime frequencies?
Well, the day frequencies that I put in your folder, I pretty much everybody has day frequencies in their folders and they're just to use if you have time.
There are some people that never use them, there are some people that do it every day.
So I certainly, if you're feeling great and you've improved and you've got your energy back, I'd rather have you outside, gardening and living your life and playing with your kids or your grandkids than having to sit at the rice machine.
But if you are going to sit down and read a book or study or watch TV or something like that, then turn on one of your main programs.
Is it okay to use castor oil on the infected breast when what is hormone positive? I would be careful with that.
We've had people try castor oil packs over their breast.
Some people have said it or they felt it was great and it helped flush it out.
But I've had people say it got way more inflamed and it aggravated it and made it very angry. So I would be very careful with that.
So since I've experienced that over the years, I've always advocated just to use castor oil packs over the liver.
I've had mixed reviews of women taking flax seeds or flax seed oil with hormone positive breast cancer. What's your opinion?
I would agree. There are mixed reviews out there. I followed in the camp of no because there's too much data that flax seeds and flax seed oil is estrogenic.
And we don't want that. So I would fall into the no category on that.
If we have other people that have different cancers and they're using flax seed oil or they're using the blood with blood weight protocol, which is flax seed oil.
But they don't have ER positive cancer. So if you have hormone positive cancer, then I would say no.
Hello, thank you for your help. I would like to help a friend with our knife machine. Are there any specific programs that you'd suggest for neuropathy in their legs and feet?
Yeah, the neuropathy programs. So there's neuropathy programs in the true right folder. There's neuropathy programs in the atelier robin folder.
So either one of those could be helpful, but always with with any disease, you always want to ask that one question. Why so why do they have neuropathy?
Do they have diabetic neuropathy? Do they have chemo and doosteropathy? Those are the things that you want to use. You really want to deal with the cause, right?
So if the person has diabetic neuropathy, well, you certainly can use the right neuropathy programs, but you deal with if you don't deal with the diabetes, you're not going to really be ultimately helping that person.
Now, if the person has neuropathy because they did chemo a year ago and they're done with that, but now they have this neuropathy within my all means, you know, just jump into this.
The causative factor is, you know, done, you know, you don't have to make changes there. Also detox seed as much as possible can be helpful if it's something like that.
Not diabetes, but chemo therapy because chemo therapy induced neuropathy is from basically the toxicity of the chemo therapy actually killing the nerves.
So helping detox would be helpful too. Sorry, I shouldn't read the rest of the question. She said she's not diabetic and it's not from heavy metals. It was diagnosis unspecified neuropathy.
She also has two bad deeds that the doctors say need replacing.
So still, I mean, she's got to get diagnosed. There's not there's some causes of neuropathy.
If it's in the hands and the feet, what's in her legs and her feet, then it certainly could be just neurological because of blood flow.
I don't, you know, you do have to do a full di differential diagnosis is the person have heart issues. If they have, you know, weakness in their heart, they might not be getting good blood flow to their to their legs, especially if she's got two bad needs that could be blocking blood flow.
There could be stasis, even if the person has diabetes, you could still have sugar stasis in the lower extremities.
So that could be the cause of it. Certainly looking at the rebuilder would be helpful too, but if you don't deal with the cause, then that's not going to really be the answer, but definitely I would definitely use the right. That's for sure.
Okay, questions from the stat chat.
I wear jewelry designed to block EMFs. Would the jewelry block the right frequency? No, nope, you're fine. That's not going to block the right frequency.
So the jewelry that helps block EMFs, technically it doesn't block EMFs. It's it's designed to help mitigate the negative effect of the bad electromagnetic frequencies.
So it won't be too dead to anything that were running on the right. I just had a dental composite feeling which usually is a challenge for me. The procedure went well, just wondered if there's a right program that would help my body accept this.
No, but there's right. So when you get a feeling, when you get dental work, you're always more susceptible to dental infections that could be hidden.
So there's a lot of dental programs on the right. So if you look on the right, there's several dental programs, the dental infection program, I would run that.
So whenever you get dental work done, remember you're going to be more susceptible to or you might already have hidden dental infections. That's the problem with root canal teeth and such.
You got this some some clinical infection that is just constantly, you know, taking a toll on your immune system.
So running those programs on the right can be beneficial.
I have had a Vintaligo for many years, but no new spots for 25 years. I noticed while in Florida that most of my legs and arms have changed colors. Why would this be?
Would it be from the Kisqually? Well, Vintaligo is there. If you look it up, it's not really don't know what causes it. I have my own theories. I think it's an autoimmune condition.
And certainly this quiz quality is going to make that worse. So yes, I would say that makes that that could make that worse.
I assume you've researched all the EMF blocking products on your website. I am just so skeptical that a sticker works on a cell phone or jewelry, as mentioned earlier, really works.
Well, I said over and over again that nothing is going to block the EMF's. Well, I should take the back. Yes. If you put your your phone in a Faraday cage, that's what a Faraday cage is. This is a completely blocks all reception.
So those little, those little cloth, um, Faraday cages, so Faraday cages, anything, it's not cage, but anything that blocks EMF's like truly blocks EMF's.
So how do you know if it blocks EMF's, if you put your phone in our bank, you know, that we have, you know, unless you're standing pretty close to a tower, you won't get it.
You won't hear the, if somebody calls you, it won't go through because it's blocked the communication.
You know, and we have on our store bags that you can put over your, your, your internet box in the house and it can help block that, but the problem is you, if you block your internet, you won't be able to use your internet in your house.
So you can't completely block stuff. If you blocked, if you had your phone in a Faraday cage, and you completely blocked, you can't use your phone.
So well, that's what I want. I just, I just want my phone to shut off so that I can't receive any messages. Okay, well then that's where you get those bags and you can put your phone in a bag overnight.
So you can't get any calls. Well, I'm hesitant personally to do that because we got, you know, a bunch of kids with the bunch of grandkids.
And, you know, there's an emergency and they have to call us the night we wouldn't be able to get their calls. We would, it's not, the phone is just turned off. It can't receive anything.
So it's completely blocked. So what's, to me, the best alternative then is honestly those, the safe sleeps are my favorite.
We used to sell them, but then there's too many different qualifications at different folds. So there's too many skews to keep and we just stop selling the slate.
So I tell people just to go on to safesleeve.com and get it. That's what I use on my phone. It's kind of a hard case.
So it's not to be able to like it because it increases the bulk of your phone, but that's what that's the best blockage where you could still receive messages. Now I have a safe sleeve and a sticker on my phone.
The stickers don't block EMS nor do the pendants block EMS like I stated before they're just helping change the negative effects of the EMS.
So you don't have as many negatives. Nothing is going to do it completely unless you put your whole body into a fairer day cage.
So nothing is going to work. None of those things are going to work perfectly. So it's just the way it is. We live in a world full of bad frequencies that are going through us.
Would your product for hormones work better than because quality no, no, I mean, I would never say that it's supplement is going to do is good job as a medication.
So, but that's kind of why people, you know, the medication has all these negative side effects that, you know, aren't pleasant and cause issues.
So people don't necessarily like to stay on those medications for that reason. So then they, they want to get on something that is is maybe going to be a little bit, you know, less toxic to them.
Have you seen those patch products where they say they're using frequencies to help people with all sorts of problems.
I was skeptical, but I know someone who has was allergic to everything. It had several issues. And now she's better. Yes, I have heard of those two. We have used them. We've had them in our store different times, but we don't carry them currently.
And I do think that they have efficacy. They can't argue with a lot of the testimonials that are out there of people that said that they thought that it's really it really helped them. So, I think there can be benefit to them.
It just shows again how frequencies can be beneficial to you.
And I think really how that works if they go, how does the patch actually put out frequencies. I think what the patch does is it's doing similar to the phone things is that it, you know, you are exposed to frequencies and it changes those to be beneficial frequencies for you.
No, again, I've had some people and I've used those and say that it, you know, it doesn't help didn't help them at all. But you could hear that about everybody too. So, but I do think it, I think it can have efficacy. I think you can have benefits.
Any other questions? All right. Well, thanks for being on today. Sorry. I kind of have no voice left at the end of the day. Yes, you did miss the first question that came up. So you have to listen to the recording. I'll get that up right away. All right. Bye. Bye, everybody.